هذه شبكات متداخله شبكه متداخله اللي هو
مصلحه المملكه بصبيتها اكبر دوله
مصدره للبترول واعتماد الاقتصاد السعودي
على البترول
واحتياطياتا الى ستمتد باذن الله الى
ثمانين عاما او اكثر وفي نفس على الاقل
يعني حاسب الانتاج الحالي وفي نفس الوقت
لنا علاقه قويه مع دول منتجه اخرى وبهدف
تنظيم السوق والعمل معا من اجل توازنها
قال لي هو الاوبك والاوبك بس
ثالثا الاقتصاد العالمي الاقتصاد العالمي
طبعا يهمنا نموه وقوته يجب ان ننسى
موضوع عن هام جدا ان الطلب على البترول
واستلامته يعتمد على وضع الاقتصاد العالمي
وصحه الاقتصاد العالمي ونمو الاقتصاد
العالمي في الدرجه الاولى ولذلك هذه
المنظومه الثلاثيه
تهمنا جميعا بدون بدون ان نفرق بين هذا
الارتباطهما مع بعض